[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically by talking with you
coaching you in your money in your work
and in your relationships the phone
number to jump in is 88255
2258 8255 225 I'm Ken Coleman and I'm
with the lovely the talent the
enthusiastic the Unstoppable the
incomparable she's still waving me on
here Jade warshaw and we are here for
you Jade you ready to go let's go I must
tell you for the YouTube audience you're
going to have to uh make sure you really
check out the fit today she is look at
it she's going to stand up she's rocking
the Air Jordan is that uh actually suede
is it suede it's it's a the suede
sweatsuit that's what I like to say call
it suede yeah suede sweatsuit I am just
rocking the bronny shirt uh because I
couldn't find anything else in the clock
but we are here for you that's your
choice kenice what we're wearing we are
here for you David is up in Springfield
Massachusetts David how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call you
bet what's up all righty so I am a
mattress salesman I'm currently driving
an hour to work every day and back um I
have zero debt my total cost of living
is $700 a month that includes $520 for
gas now I was wondering if I should
um move out towards there because I
currently am not paying rent so that
could jack up my cost of living but it
could take a lot of stress off of myself
or I can move within the company to a
location closer to where I live like
within five to 10 minutes there's no
guarantee I'd stay at one store though
and it could possibly lower my income so
I was just wondering what I should do
okay so no to lowering the income so
that's not an option cuz you have too
many other options in this economy right
now to where there's just no viable
reason for you to lower your income
right so making the move closer to the
current role to me is the best option
you've given me I'll give you another
option in a minute let me tell you why
yes you're going to have to pay rent but
you know what that's called adulting
it's time you know to do that anyway
number two you're going to save money on
the gas but you're also going to take
less wear and tear or put less wear and
tear on the car too so I think if I look
at less wear and tear Jade and I look at
less gas money and I look at less stress
those are three viable reasons to move
closer to the current job now the third
option is all right let me look at uh a
better job if you want to be a mattress
sales and that's put setting you up for
a better position within that company
then I think you go option two which is
moving closer but I I look at a third
option which is can I make more money
can I get on a a better ladder and and
and remove the drop
uh as well that would be my favorite
option but I'm curious what is that
professional future what are you
thinking
about um I mean I didn't really have a
direction till I got into sales so I do
personally love Sal just working with
people and everything so I definitely
would like to keep it in there um going
to school and becoming an electrician
was also an option just being being in
the trades um love that I just don't I
currently I just don't know if I want to
if want to take out student loans or
just save up for that how old are you 18
18 yeah all right so because you don't
and by the way it's very normal to be 18
and not know what you want to do with
your life okay so I say we go to moving
closer to the current sales job that's
going to change your life we laid out
all the positives to that all right now
you begin to think do I really want to
make the move and go to trade school and
be an electrician do I want to go into
Plumbing do I want to do something else
and I'm going to give you my get clear
career assessment as my gift an early
Christmas gift for you and the book from
paycheck to purpose think of the
assessment as a compass and the book as
the guide to climb the mountain that you
choose because I at 18 you have plenty
of time to experiment and check this out
and get some awareness of who you are
and what you want to do why you want to
do it and where you can do it that's the
next step so stability is key Jade you
cannot make big life decisions when
you're stressed out facts and you know
you're driving 2 hours in the car and
you're frustrated you need some life
stability some that will lead to life
Clarity I'm going play against you on
one of these though of course you are um
here it comes folks so here's the one
thing that I would also think through I
think what Ken said was great um and
really really good advice but there was
one thought of it that I thought okay
well if you do Ken's assessment and you
start getting Clarity around something
that you would like to do that requires
some form of investment on some form of
Education I'm not saying it's college
but maybe it's you know something that's
going to cost you to get the training
that you need there could be a piece of
this words good for you to stay where
you're at
temporarily um in order to save money
because your cost of living is so very
low that might be the margin that you
need to that at all I don't disagree so
I my point here is I don't want him to
go backwards financially so
he gets a better paying job locally
that's right that's right the point is
uh it's not urgent for you to be like
I've got to make this Choice instantly I
want you to do kin's thing first and
then that's going to inform what your
what your choice is next that's right
makes sense David yeah absolutely and
one last thing I think I was a little
unclear on the income so it is a flat
rate or commission so it it's a
possibility of lowering my income
however that's not a definite so like I
could be making even more money by
moving closer um I didn't know that was
an option my that's my yeah so I wasn't
clear about that I'm sorry yeah so
here's what Jaden I say we're in
complete agreement I just want you to be
stable I want you to make that work
Rhythm here here's what I know and I'm
getting ready to post right now on the
commercial break I'm going to Instagram
I was working on this and I'm reading
all this well-being at work stuff let me
tell you something if you're sick of
your job I can promise you you're sick
because of your
job I'm getting ready to post that and
so when when a young like this is and
anybody is driving all that hours and
you're you get sick literally you know
what I'm
saying emotionally and then that leads
to the physical lack of Wellness so uh
my advice David was I want you to be
well so that we can make the right
choice but if you can stay local meaning
we switch jobs and we don't go backwards
financially I agree with Jade that is
the best choice for all of the reasons
the the car wear and tear the gas money
uh the rent hey you're saving money on
rent right now I love that move uh and
oh by the way I get to stabilize my life
that's right and then I decide is it
welding is it electrici whatever use you
know and I know you mentioned
electrician work but can I give you
quick piece of advice on the electrician
piece I want to challenge you in the
next two weeks to go to coffee or lunch
or a cocktail with an electrician or
two and I want you to just go hey I'm
thinking about kicking the tires on this
deal and going into this before I do
tell me what you love what you what you
hate The Good The Bad how did you start
when did you launch your own business I
would love for you to get that advice
from an electrician I Jade I can't say
that enough for young don't you have to
be 21 to have a cocktail K oh I forgot
look at you catching me all the
particulars well I'm just playing you
got me on that one I'm not promoting
underage drinking at all I forgot that
he was 18 no cocktails David all right
get yourself an O DS do they still sell
that trash aa oh that's cocktail I think
is it it's got alcohol near beer yeah
just cuz you put the Jolly Rancher in it
doesn't take the alcohol away we have
lost we have lost the train let's get it
back on the tracks hang on the line
daveid we got the get clear assessment
and from paycheck to purpose but you get
some great options my friend thanks for
the call don't move more Randy show
coming
up
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win in your money life your
work life and your relationship life I'm
Ken Coleman Jade warshaw joins me the
phone number is8 8255 225 Jade is uh one
of our money experts uh here on the
Ramsey Show and uh I am the work I don't
even like ever using the word expert but
I help people win at work how about that
if you're winning at your work life
here's what I know you have a better
chance of winning than the rest of your
life so wherever you at on the journey
maybe you're not happy at work you want
to make some more money you want to
launch the side hustle get out of debt I
want to help you make more money while
we're in the baby steps how about that
and so to the extent that we could take
any of those calls I'm here for that
Jade is ready to go for you as well we
continue with Preston in Columbus Ohio
Preston how can we
help hey how's it going um I work a job
where I have to move every three-ish
years uh and I rent currently and I
didn't know if I should continue renting
or when I move next I should look to buy
a home because I've heard that you
shouldn't buy a home unless you plan on
living on it for at least like five
years and so I didn't know if I should
continue renting for the rest of my
career or should I try to buy a home so
how much longer do you plan to be on in
the
military um I'm doing the whole 20 so
still got 18 more years okay is it just
you or are you married do you have kids
I'm married with one kid and one kid on
the way okay cool um you know I think
you need to take it on a case-by Case
basis so far you've made it this long
without buying correct you're currently
renting yeah okay yeah I'm currently
renting I think there's something
important about you know not stacking up
a bunch of real estate in different
states and cities um two years is kind
of where you want to be as far as like
not having to take on um capital gains
and things like that so I think if you
can take it on a case-by casee basis
because at at some point purchasing real
estate is going to be a big part of your
wealth building but I don't think that
you're there yet I think right now that
you you can continue to rent and as
you've been in the military longer if
you end up being stationed somewhere
longer and it seems like this is going
to be at least four or five years it
could be worth it to get into real
estate buy a home and then if you know
you're moving somewhere and it's going
to be a short-term thing whatever that
profit you have just pocket it put it in
high yield and let it grow whatever baby
step you're on that sort of thing
um until you can buy again longterm does
that make
sense yeah currently we we save so we
have our rent obviously but then we also
save uh we have a brokerage that we call
our house fund that we put money into
I'm fine with that kind of figured we we
wouldn't be buying a home for a very
what we assume was a very long time we
figured we just invest it into a
brokerage and then when I whenever we
can buy a home we have this nice pot of
money to pull very long time what's that
number in your head
head Well we'd like to build a home
eventually and that's probably when I
retire so like 18 years from now okay I
I love Jade's advice and we get a lot of
these calls from folks in the military
and a lot of the advice you get is you
know what you guys can everywhere you go
buy a house and now you've building a
real estate portfolio I know heard
terrible we really want you to avoid
that Temptation and and and Jake can
explain why but I would just say
this you think about 18 years from now
you think about that home fund that
they're investing in that is going to be
a sweet down payment on the house you
want to maybe cash and so I love the
idea of you guys renting or taking
advantage of military housing and just
stack cash to build the home of your
dreams I think that'll keep you going if
you keep your mind on I'm just playing a
little mindset thing here and I I'll get
back to Jade but my mindset would be how
sweet of a home could we build or how
could we pay off you know I mean pay
cash for this house we want to build and
it's just 18 years let me tell you
something my friend I'm old enough to
remember going H 18 years is a long time
and I can sit here today and tell you 18
years goes by fast man what baby step
are you
on um currently we have no debt except
for um student loans okay so as much as
I love the picture that you're painting
and I love the idea that you're thinking
ahead and putting money away in a
brokerage um I'd like to get you a
little bit more focused so that we can
get to this beautiful reality that Ken
is painted and even the reality that
you're saying of hey in 18 years this is
when we're going to do our dream home so
let's pedal back just for a second and
make sure that we're going about all of
this in the most efficient way possible
is that
fair yeah okay so how familiar with you
are how familiar are you with our baby
steps I I know yeah I've listened to
Dave for a while okay so then you're
well aware that first we want to get
$1,000 saved do you have that yeah yep
okay You' got so we've got U emergency
fund that's a little over 20,000 okay um
sitting in a savings account great um
and how much student loans and uh I have
about five left and then my wife has
about 10 okay so if you're following the
plan then you know that the first things
first is we keep $1,000 and we take any
extra money and we throw it at our debt
right yeah and I think the only reason
we didn't do uh do that is um we both
have the military paying our um student
loans so we get payments alongside our
payments what does that look like
longterm um they'll pay it off
completely yeah complete off completely
I um like my loan I so I just got out of
school here recently um my loan was
originally 10,000 the Army's already
paid five of it off in the last like
three years while I was in school they
were paying on it paying on it if you
pay them off early will they reimburse
you
no are you they pay they don't pay me
they pay the the loan provider directly
so if there's no need for them to pay
the loan direct or loan provider they
won't pay them interesting interesting
all right I'm gonna let that slide
because I know that that's going to go
yeah which is why we didn't tackle them
aggressively as we did when we got out
of like Consumer Debt so you're not on
the hook for any of this
whatsoever I mean we make payments
alongside and so we're making payments
but I've I've done the the math uh what
I'm trying to understand what I'm trying
to understand here is is it worth it for
you to cuz if you're paying payments now
if if if if their promise to you is hey
we're going to repay all of this I'm not
really sure why you're making payments
now so part of you go ahead they don't
so they pay alongside side us so we pay
they they pay but we have to be in good
standing so the loan provider says hey
this is your monthly you know due and we
pay that and what's your monthly
du um I think my wife's owes like two
like 10 a month and then I pay like 70
online okay so she pays 210 and you pay
70 and then they match your
payment um they match yeah they match
your payment based off it's weird they
like a weird room but they pay about
,500 a year okay so I would just love
for you to get clarity on that because I
would hate for you to kick this around
for five and six years a piece I would
love to find out and get clarity and be
like hey I I I want my cut of this but I
also don't want to be paying payments
for the next 10 years as is there any
way that I can pay up and get my part of
this done and then you guys pay your
portion of it so do a little research on
that for me because I want you to get
the money that they're happy to pay but
I also don't want you doing this for
like years and years and years to come
is that fair enough yeah it's fair we
we're pretty we was pretty sure they'll
be paid off within the next like three
years and it's like I know the month but
with me moment and that's with you just
keeping this payment as it is you don't
have to do anything and they they pay
based off of the initial principle so
like my loan was a
$10,000 uh $10,000 loan so they paid a
certain percentage of that initial
principal and they keep paying based off
the principal whether the principal
because now it's at like 5,000 but they
still pay that I it's like like last
payment was like 16 I still okay I still
stand by what I said and I'd still look
and see is there any way I can make this
thing go faster because I don't want to
pay payments for three three more years
so just check into it it'll make me
sleep better at night um okay and then
are you so that would put you to baby
step three are you currently investing
15% I just want to make sure you're
doing these baby steps and then the next
thing is putting aside for that house so
go through check and make sure those
things are clicking for you if they are
you're doing excellent I'm just poking
holes in this because you're already
doing so well I want to make sure that
you're just like you're already running
fast I just want to make sure that
you're win the race is basically what it
boils down to I like it good job Coach
Jay thank you for the call Preston hey
don't move we're going to take a quick
break coming back with more of your
calls this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at ch ministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is my partner in
crime today8 825 5225 8825 5225 talking
about your money Jade's here our our
resident money Guru and I'm going to
talk with you about your work as it
relates to your income maybe you're not
so happy where you are and you're going
can I make a transition while I'm in the
baby steps the answer is yes we can walk
you through how to do that remember
Davis said for decades your income is
your greatest wealth build tool and I
want to help you with your income I
think you can make more money and
experience more meaning and so that's
very relevant I'm here to help out on
those work questions so let's get right
back to the phones uh going back to my
old stomping grounds here in the hot
Atlanta area Ricky is on the line Ricky
how can we help hey how's it going guys
um I'm in baby step two and my question
is how should I best set myself up for
uh filling my boss's old position
position o I love this question K that's
right up your Alleyway I love this we're
talking promotion here we're talking
more pay right Ricky correct correct
tell me what we know right now where do
we stand is the position officially open
is the boss saying I okay tell me what
more yeah so it's it's officially open
um his last day is
tomorrow um I've already talked with my
boss's boss and told him you know I want
to apply and he welcomed that
um but kind of let me know that he's
looking for someone who has a lot of uh
leadership capacity or experience in
managing a team or on the other and the
job is Facilities Management um so just
experience and knowledge in that field
you know managing a budget uh those kind
of things so um those are the kind of
two things that I think is going to play
against me because I don't necessarily
have that experience and and it sounds
to me like the boss set you up the
boss's boss set you up and and I and I
I'm gonna give the real real always that
was a bit of a stiff arm har well sure I
welcome that but I'm looking for and uh
so it's kind of a way of going I don't
see you as a as maybe the top candidate
but I love your question anyway Ricky I
love your spunk because you felt the
stiff arm and you still called me and
said how do I change that perception so
this is what I'm going to lean into okay
all right what experience do you have in
those two areas where you don't have a
lot do you have
some yeah I think I have I think I have
more leadership experience than he
realizes like I've had two direct
reports for about a year and a half um
as as far as like leading a team but
yeah um as far as like my college
basketball experience you play college
basketball uh yeah small small it don't
matter it don't matter you're talking to
a guy who would have probably chewed my
right leg off to play D3 or niia or that
would have been problematic once I made
the team if I only had one leg but you
get my point I really really really
think that that is a huge huge thing for
you to talk about leadership in the
college basketball setting I would talk
about what you love most about leading
those two direct reports see here's
here's what I don't want you I don't
want you to go in and go look I've done
this and I've done that that's great I
want him to see you light up when you
talked about being a captain or a leader
in the program I would tell a story um
what was the leadership role how would
you describe your leadership role in the
basketball
team yeah I mean being a point guard
floor General uh leading the team and um
you know multiple different ways here's
what I want you to do instead of talking
about what you did I want you to talk
about
how you led which is I was a point guard
and then I want you talk about what you
loved most about the pressure of leading
yeah that's a narrative now same thing
with the two direct reports I've had
these two people report to me uh for the
last year or whatever it is and I really
really enjoy this I'm really challenged
by this do you see how we're going to
create because it's one thing to go I've
LED and I think I can do a good job and
it's another thing for him to see your
heart and to see your face light up when
you talk about leading as a servant or
however you want to describe your
leadership style I that would be the
only advice I'm going to give you cuz I
think you're quite capable as a guy who
is a point guard you know how to
distribute the rock baby that's what a
good point guard does we get into the
set we're looking at the play when I got
to add lib I'm gonna add lib but I am
the captain on the floor I would grab
that narrative and just say listen
what's his name by the
way uh who my boss the boss's boss make
up a name make up a name Bob okay Bob
Bob listen to me thank you for even
encouraging me I know you're probably
looking for somebody with this
experience in this and this experience
here and I get that but but listen
because you give me the opportunity I
want you to hear my heart here's why I
want this gig and why I believe with
your leadership I can fill the Gap
that's the narrative and the logistics I
would just say the same deal tell them
what experience you have on the
logistics side but really it's about the
people on the team they know what
they're supposed to do your job is to
help them do their job go and if I'm Bob
I want to I'm I'm happy to hear you talk
about all that stuff I also want to know
how it transfers I want to if I'm Bob I
want to hear you say I understand
certain things about this job and here's
how that skill transfers into that
here's how I see it helping that's part
of what I want to see
and at the very least coming out of this
Ken and you can tell me if I'm off track
this is this is your field I'd also be
asking questions about kind of knowing
going in that he was given the stiff arm
I'd also want to know what the track is
and some of my questions would be like
what how do I attain it like how do I
get there um what do you have in mind
for me reaching this next level that
kind of thing yeah either way I love
that advice you know what that that's at
the end though that's at the end that's
at the end and then you go listen thank
you for the opportunity to share my
heart now if this doesn't work out
here's what I'd love what can I do how
can I do it MH to get an opportunity
next time I love that advice from Jade I
think that's great I sure that's that's
good and I've like even thought about or
had some mentors suggest looking into
some you know commercial HVAC education
you know certification courses things
like that but no that's really good I
appreciate Hey listen Ricky last piece
yeah yeah last piece on this and this is
all mindset stuff all right this is my
favorite I I love to coach my favorite
thing is on the mindset here is you have
nothing to lose if I was talking to my
te right now I'd say look there is zero
risk um I feel like I've given you a
nice little framework you choose to use
what you want but you go in with
confidence take your shot you're a point
guard baby five four three two take the
shot and get yourself in the best
position for the shot and then be okay
if you miss the shot Michael Jordan
famously uh I got Jordan's on today me
too you and I both what you got I just
got the old school there we go old
school sneaks there uh here's the deal
Jordan said once and I'm
paraphrasing I'm known for making the
last second shots those clutch shots but
the fact is I've missed thousands more
I'm paraphrasing than I've ever made in
that clutch moment right and the thing
is Michael Jordan for all of his
greatness and by the way for all the
people out there yes he's the greatest
it's not
LeBron it ain't LeBron take your LeBron
stuff and just I'll I'll raise you a
Michael Air Jordan okay nothing against
LeBron do no I got I got it against
LeBron well see I don't people think
because I say Air Jordan that I'm
against LeBron it's not true he's just
not the greatest the goat is Michael
anyway the point is we're on the same
team is all I'm saying I know Michael
was the goat because he was willing to
keep taking the shot MH and also cuz he
won the most but fact more Rings yes
that's right um it makes me can I just
go into something that I'm already
seeing you go there and I'm out of the
way look there's an episode of Family
Matters where Harriet goes to apply for
the job that she knows she's not
qualified for I love it and they're like
trying to give her the stiff arm and
she's like they're like you're not
qualified and she goes into this whole
rant about how raising a family gives
her the so like the transferable skills
to actually do the job she's like I
manage the budget I'm the D like she
goes into this whole thing and at the
end of the day she gets the job Ken
because she's the CEO of the house
that's right he better shoot his shot
you never know it it might be winning
shot this is where you come to get
incredible life advice and a strong
opinion on the greatest basketball
player to ever live Michael Jordan This
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us net week worked for ramsy and it
will make a difference for your business
too join the more than 34,000 customers
who trust netsuite to help make them
smarter and make better decisions and
level up their operations to learn more
get a free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win with your money win in your
work and win in your relationships I'm
Ken Coleman Jade warshaw is my co-host
cohort and we are here for you the phone
number to jump in Isle 88255 225 of
course Jay's going to take care of those
money questions but hey I'm in the seat
today which means we can talk about your
work and your work is tied to your money
you want to make more money you want to
launch a side hustle maybe 2024 is where
we increase the income with the side gig
uh or we get the raise because we
finally say it's time to move so we're
going to talk about it's the year for
all that it is it's all of it and above
so here we go Sacramento California is
where we go next and Daniel joins us
there Daniel how can we help hi Ken and
Jade I'm glad to be here well we're glad
you're here what is
happening well um my parents are in
their late 70s early
80s and um they're um thinking that they
want to put my sister and I on their
bank account and in case something
happens that we can access funds and
just in General um my dad has a debil
debilitating disease um and so my Mom
feels like she's kind of the only one
and if something happens to her she
wants you know it gives her a sense of
security I think and so I just want to
think if you think that's a bad idea for
for us to to be on on my parents
accounts bank accounts I I don't think
it's a bad idea you're probably are you
the power of attorney for your
dad no power of attorney
uh my mom makes all the decisions you
know he's still you know in good shape
and and motoring along but it's a it's a
degenerative disease it won't get better
it'll only get worse and so um but
there's no power of attorney right now
or anything they just like for the first
time we did it last week we just were
you know brought our IDs to the bank
they added us on the account and that
was it so um I don't think it's
necessarily a bad idea the only question
mark I have is she's worried that
something would happen and you guys
would need access to the money but not
her like I I guess I'm trying to figure
out what's the scenario that she's
concerned about yeah the scenario that
she's concerned about is that if
something happens to her my dad can't
really make good decisions um so that's
I think our primary concern sense what
would happen and so yeah yeah you know I
I'm not mad about that
um yeah I'd say go for it it's I don't
have any red flags on it as long as it's
just the bank account I mean it's not
like you're being added to debt accounts
and things like that um I'd absolutely
do it unless you I was wondering if you
any red flags I mean this makes a lot of
sense I think there's a lot of wisdom
here given their health and their age
yeah do they both have
Wills uh yeah they have a I believe I
know they have a trust okay great great
and the thing I like about this too
Daniel they came to you on this you're
not you're not nosing into this there's
no tension here
it just feels right am I am I correct do
you have any misgivings about it is that
why in other words why did you call with
that question which way were you leaning
well when when I asked her why we were
doing it she said well all my friends
have done it and so it seems to be like
the thing to do and I and I you know I I
want to support them 100% it's just that
that that didn't seem like a great
reason to me I I I wanted it to more to
just kind of think through if it makes
sense or not and you know yeah that was
basically yeah well there's not really
um unless unless you're not trustworthy
there's not too much of there's no
downside that I can find and if I really
put myself in your shoes um if my
parents were getting up in
age I and if especially if there was any
you know
degenerative um disease at play I
certainly would want access to that
stuff sooner than later so you know just
in case so really putting myself in your
shoes I would do the exact same thing um
I don't know that my parents there's
four of kids I don't know that they
would give all four of us access to
their account not that we're not all
trustworthy but it's just not necessary
one person kind of heading up the thing
makes sense um and in your mom's case I
could totally understand that being
something that she's concerned about I
don't know about the thing of you know
oh all my friends are doing it that
might be her reason um her reason but my
reason would just be hey it is important
that someone um who can really think
through things cognitively has access to
this money in case something were to
happen to her and and money was needed
that just makes sense to me so I'm good
with it yeah thanks for the call Daniel
let's go now to Knoxville Tennessee
Christian is there Christian how can we
help hey how y'all doing good how are
you sir good good so make this short and
brief um I'm 25 I got probably about 30
30 plus thousand in depth um I'm a tower
hand I make make roughly on 8 hour day
$200 a day but I got a car loan that I
haven't you know that I got to for I got
Medical debet in collection um here
recently um I just had the state of
Mississippi come after me for child
support um so they're going to be coming
after me pretty quick for that um I'm
I'm gone I work Monday through Friday
I'm home on the
weekends uh I'm just trying to figure
out some way to basically get more
Financial Freedom and get out of debt
and have a have a better lifestyle I
reckon okay um
so let's start first things first uh so
you're making what about 5,000 bucks a
month uh 4500
4,000 I'd say I'd say more closer to
like 36 on the good month okay is that
after
taxes yeah okay um and you said you've
got around 30,000 of debt do you know
the exact
number um no ma'am okay that's thing one
the first thing here is to in order to
get organ to understand what the problem
is we've got to see it for what it is so
when you get off the phone today I want
you to go check all you know log into
all those accounts and see exactly what
the debt is if you could um sparse it
out what type of debt is it you may not
know the exact amounts but can you tell
me what type of debt it
is uh more like personal loans and stuff
like that for the vehicle auto loan you
know and and I just know when I look at
it on my uh like some of my credit apps
and stuff like that they just say
they're in Collections and stuff you
know so is everything in
collections I believe so okay so right
now it's just kind of it's like you've
been going along all this stuff is
happening and you're just kind of like
letting it take place the fact that
we're not really sure what the Deb is
we're not really sure how much the
amount is do you kind of see this theme
playing out
here well I got I got some of my uh some
of my debt mainly the auto loan and a
couple of the uh couple of the health
uh like Hospital loans or Hospital
collections I got them in a a debt
relief program I pay like
$380 a month for them to basically keep
it in a savings account and they
negotiate prices with them and he
Christian Christian listen I'm I'm G to
shoot you straight we're going to get
you some help he he needs one of our
coaches but let me tell you what I think
you need to hear your hands have not
been on the wheel mhm you you are just I
I even know I don't think it's Jesus
Take the Wheel but somebody has taking
the wheel and it ain't you and you
listen nothing nothing against you at
all I'm trying to be a wakeup call to
you you've got you got children you're
supposed to be supporting and you're not
and the state's coming after you and
everything's just been kind of like I'm
letting life happen to me and I think
you need to start happening to life so
one of the things that you need to start
to do is as Jade said is get aware of
what's going on and I want to give you a
free session with one of our financial
coaches but you have got to do what they
tell you to do the second thing is you
better start making some more money you
you need to be working crazy hours with
the skill set you have because that will
help you do what Jade's coaching you you
got to get some more income and start
putting it to
work well see I also that's uh a
question is is I pay I pay a lot in rent
you know um I live by myself I have a
service dog but I live by myself and I
live in a three-bedroom single wide
trailer and I pay $1,200 to live change
that you know go live with somebody
else well see with with the with the the
state of Mississippi wanting child's
Sport and I figured later on there might
come a a a child's a child custody case
I also need somewhere to call my own
with that room for my for my child well
we cross that bridge when we get there
or go get your two-bedroom you getting
all this you getting this mess cleaned
up it's what's going to ultimately even
give you a dog in that hunt but right
now you don't have a dog in the hunt you
got to get your mess cleaned up and
you've really got to show that this
matters to you cuz right now I hear a
guy that's kind of like if it happens
cool if it doesn't happen no big deal
like there's you got to go somewhere and
find that enthusiasm to really make this
happen for yourself get out of that debt
consolidation thing that ain't working
for you hang on the line we're going to
get you a session on us with one of our
financial coaches great hour Jade
warshaw thanks to James Childs and the
crew this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramy shower it's
where we help you win in your money life
your work life and your relationship
life the phone number is tri8 8255 225
I'm Ken colan Jade warshaw joins me
she's our money Guru I'll be helping you
on work related questions because that
plays into your money Big Time 88255 225
let's go to Tiffany who joins us in
Cleveland Ohio Tiffany how can we help
hi uh thank you for taking my call um I
so basically I'm an aesthetician um so I
have my own spa room um I've been here
for two and a half years um and my
business is doing great especially
starting off during the pandemic mhm um
I have Lupus so this isn't really the
greatest job for me but this is what I
love to do and that's the one thing that
I'm actually good at okay um so when I
work myself too hard you know it flares
up I have a hard time um my husband and
I have been married for eight years um
and together four before that he is a
juvenile probation off officer with a
bachelor's degree okay um I guess my my
main thing is is that's the job that
he's been in for 13 years now okay um
we're seeing a counselor we're kind of
working on things but I'm finding myself
getting
frustrated uh with the fact that
he you know kind of refuses to go and
find a better job that would pay better
what's he make um he only he makes 2,000
every two weeks okay so 4,000 a month
after taxes yes after taxes
yeah so I bring in more than that um
what do you bring in so on average like
3,000 3,500 or so a month um I thought
you said he did
4,000 oh no no no sorry
two I'm sorry
2,464 a month that's him
2,464 a month yes okay yes sorry sorry
what is his job again he's a juvenile
probation officer so has a bachelor's
degree okay and is he salary or
hourly he's salary what's his
salary what is it 40 40 45 something in
that range 40 it's got to be like 40
okay yes so then after taxes and
insurance and all that good stuff let's
so this is not about numbers this entire
call is not about numbers this is about
you feeling like he should be uh or
excuse me he could be and he should be
making more money be doing more yes yeah
and it's creating a lot of tension yes
and am I being unreasonable I don't have
a degree you know I I don't no but the
way you're going about it might be so
what is the narrative when you sit down
with him to the best of your
recollection how are you talking to him
about
this um I've tried it a couple different
ways I've tried saying hey you know I
can help you with your resume you know
let's let's try and see or I've tried to
say Hey you know like this is the great
time to apply to jobs they're hiring
everywhere I got to throw a FL I got to
throw a flag on the play as long as we
get back to what he said I got to get
that part what's your flag my flag on
the play is everything is you towards
him yes and I think that this is just me
again all I can tell you is how I would
do it I feel like and I know the lupus
plays into it but I feel like when
you're talking about our money and our
finances everything's got to be a we
conversation everything's got to be okay
we need to earn more what does that look
like for us to earn more and I think
that's just approach-- wise cuz and can
you complain to this but there's
something about and this is this is a
little bit old school but there's
something about when you come to
somebody it feels it almost feels like
an attack well there's no question so we
have to even if you don't want it to be
and I and come for me in the comments
but even when it's like a lady coming at
a guy about what you're making you have
the right to question it and you have
the right to want it to be different but
it's almost like there's got to be some
tactfulness getting in there because
it's almost like he's probably like the
ego part is feeling it you know what I'm
saying like yeah and he becomes
defensive he gets defensive first and
you can't get anywhere okay so here's
what we have to focus on you can't
you're giving him the what he should be
doing and you need to be focusing on
what is keeping him from doing anything
else there that's what's holding him
back so what is his language what are
the words what are the things that he's
saying back to
you um well you know he's saying well I
applied for that higher up job before
and they told me that they needed a see
more from me I went to college but it
was really easy he I don't think he has
a very good self-esteem he doesn't so
that's he do so what what I'm trying to
help you understand is as a spouse and
Jade's right but we've got to you've got
to understand what he's dealing with
he's not lazy he's
lost yeah and it presents as lazy and
I'm not saying you called him that but
this guy is he's afraid to stick his
hand back up because it's been slapped
before and he's got bad self-esteem
issues which by the way go deeper than
just what we're talking about so there's
a couple things and I'm not saying you
got to walk around building him up and
saying all these compliments but to the
extent that you can as his
spouse supporting him in the area of
what is holding him back so you're no
longer idea person and by the way I'm
not saying your heart's in the wrong
place it's not but ideas aren't the fix
you know what the fix is for him him
having a vision for his future that he
actually believes that he can get and so
I don't think he has one no he doesn't
but he can't he can't have an idea about
the future when he's clouded about the
present he doesn't believe in himself he
doesn't think he can do much more maybe
he thinks he missed the boat maybe he
thinks he's failed too many times
there's something going on and so in the
moment it's like driving a car and you
hit a patch of fog and he's hit a patch
of fog and the only thing you do when
you hit fog is slow down pull over and
wait for the fog to clear so the only
thing you can do is is speak love into
him belief into him I believe in you so
much I hate that it happened to you hey
let's have a dream night where we dream
together and instead about dreaming
about his job or dreaming about the
career path that he needs to be on why
don't you get him talking about the life
that he Longs for with you and when we
can get his head into that then you go
okay what what must be true like what
what what do we need to do collectively
together because that's the big one
that's the big one for me on this and
I'm not I'm not coming for you at all um
Tiff what I I I'm just telling you what
I heard okay and sometimes it's good to
have an impartial person cuz they can
tell you what you heard and say it back
when you initially started the call cuz
I want to make sure the talk in the
house feels right when you initially
started the call it made it kind of seem
like I've got my an esthetician thing
I've got my own room I'm making
$3500 a month it kind of made it sound
like hey I got this going on but then
and this is the one thing I know how to
do and this is what I do but then when
you kind of started talking about him it
was kind of like and he needs to do this
and he needs to do that he probably
thinks what he's doing is the thing he
knows how to do so I feel like there's
definitely needs to be a little bit more
balance in how we talk and when you
finally have this conversation it's what
both of us are doing to improve because
even though you're doing well there is
something that you can do to improve too
and that's how you keep it balanced
skills and not just you pointing a
finger at him real quick when a person
is clear Tiffany they can be confident
so I'm going to give you two tools I
want to give him the get clear
assessment will you please gift it to
him and say hey I think this will help
you see more about who you are and where
you want to go and give him the book
from paytech to purpose and then just
love him and support him this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything cost too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Jade warshaw and
we were here for youle
8825 5225 taking your money calls and
your work work related calls today 88255
225 our question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services fall is a great time of year
but nothing can get you down faster than
plumbing problems neighborly brand Mr
Rutter can handle Plumbing emergencies
as well as repairs and drain cleaning
visit neighborly decom Ramsey to find a
Mr rder near you awesome today's
question comes from Madison in
California she says I work in La as a
self-employed fitness model okay I have
worked for the same company on $10.99
for 7 years no contract involved they
just keep keep booking me the company is
looking to hire a full-time model which
would kick my position Out ooh would you
recommend I start looking for other
clients at a higher rate to diversify my
clientele or work as many hours at my
current company to make the most money
possible and pay down my debt both next
question moving on yeah I mean it it
really is uh the situation here is that
I'm going to do both I'm starting to
look no question you want to have your
head on a swivel looking for many
opportunities and and by the way she
should be doing that as a self-employed
1099 anyway you are living and breathing
off you and Sam understand that I mean
that's essentially your world you guys
were running a company you were the
musicians plus you were booking right
and so you're always looking for that
next client that uh and again what's
your max you know how many how many gigs
can you do but I would absolutely be
looking and and getting new gigs but I
would stay with them until the last
possible day when they go hey we we
hired the newer younger model that's
true um I took some Liberty with that
one I don't know if that's what they're
actually doing well I mean as an artist
you do have to diversify like that's the
name of the game there should you should
very rarely ever sign anything exclusive
so I it sounds like there's no reason
that you can't start looking for your
you know diversifying your clientele and
building up your thing
um yeah I mean
doing all that you're paying down your
debt I don't see why there's a downside
to that no not at all and I just got a
good idea in fact no it's not a good
idea it's a bad idea but I'm going to
share it with you okay I wonder what the
market is for the uh the dadbod fitness
model there's a market for everybody cuz
I you know I'm I'm not in great shape
but I'm not in bad shape maybe I could
do some of that just like the
commercials on TV they're regular guys
like there's got to be a spot for me to
sell like pickle ball equipment to
middle-aged guys yeah yeah you got the
one pack
not a sixpack that's hysterical just got
a pack I mean like like I mean you know
I'll tell you one thing you're not going
to do is ever see me modeling this kind
of shirt I see it on camera now and I go
I can't pull that off I feel like you're
modeling it now like you're just wearing
it I think nobody thinks that I would
ever wear this shirt in the woods with
an axe no you're like you're like
Hallmark you're Hallmark
movie yeah that's a stretch all right
Milwaukee Wisconsin is where Tanner
weights Tanner how can we
help hey uh I am looking for I guess
advice on how to utilize my wife and I's
savings uh to attack some debt we still
have while expecting our first child in
April great lay it out lay out the debt
for
Jay um we have 47,000 in student loan
still uh and a
$15,000 auto loan okay cool how much do
you have
saved uh we have 45,000 saved right now
okay I like that um so you've got this
baby coming along um I probably would
just honestly push paw on the baby steps
until the baby gets here and knowing
that you've got this debt knowing that
you've got this savings keeping in mind
like okay once this baby gets here or
going like ham on this what I would do
is stack up as much money as you
possibly can between now and April
magically getting to the number that
allows you to pay off your debt but
we're just sitting on it just until the
baby gets here here cuz I just want you
guys focused on that and then when the
baby gets here everything's all good
you've paid your deductible you've paid
for the baby to get here then take that
savings take all the money you've saved
up with it and knock out every penny of
this
debt sound good yeah and then you're
going to build up your three to six
months of expenses after that sure how
much money do you think you could save
between now and
April uh we could probably
save I don't know let's probably another
three to 4 thousand before then I'd say
okay yeah then I'm doing that three to 4
thousand and your wife um when she has a
baby she does her leave does she plan on
going back to work or what's the plan
for that our I guess our plan right now
is that my income would be all we kind
of be living off of and she actually is
not going to be getting any paid leave
um so I'll have to account for that as
well but so with her income out it'll be
like between 45
48 um pre-tax is what we'll kind of have
to be working with interesting and can
you're can
you're I'm a little worried about that
because right now with both of you
working there's only 3 to four months
there's only 3 to 4 thousand that you're
putting aside to pay off this debt right
and that's not going to get that's not
going to help you clear it by the time
you have the baby then you're taking
this pay cut and I'm worried that you
won't have margin to continue paying off
the Deb so what's the plan to create
that
margin right yeah I guess it would have
to be kind of limiting our expenses a
little more than we have and I guess my
thought was potentially paying off the
rest of our auto loan to free up some
more income each month but I guess I'm
not sure if that's a advised or not but
that's something I thought of just to
try to free up more of my income uh for
when that would happen you know in
Spring well that's going to get paid for
first anyway anyway right because you're
listing the debt smallest to largest
unless unless the student loans are
teeny tiny ones and you're doing those
first uh no they're they're the auto
loan is going to be smaller than the two
student loans combined okay so that's
happening regardless right when the baby
comes that 15,000 is gone and then the
rest coming out of your savings and the
3 and 4,000 is paying off I don't know
another 34,000 of student loans right
yeah give or take yeah okay so you've
got 15 or 17 left of that so that's the
money that that remainder of debt that
17,000 or so of debt that's what I want
to make sure you guys have the margin to
pay down and keep that intensity and go
quickly sure yeah so when your wife
stops working what what chunk of money
are you losing what was she
making uh 40 yeah that's a big I mean
that's half your income right there so
what would make me feel better is if
tonight or whatever night this week
works for you guys sit down and really
play out these numbers and see okay how
is this really honestly not just in our
minds because we all have the fantasy of
we have a baby and now I don't I no
longer work anymore like for a lot of
women that's what they want to do and so
you really have to look at these numbers
and see if they work because it might
just be honestly just that tweak of
going hey after after your maternity
leave even though you don't get a you
know it's not paid or whatever after
your maternity leave is it possible to
go back and work just for a little while
till we get this debt cleaned up and
then we transition to that lifestyle
because that's going to save you a lot
of months I would also like to suggest
Tanner that if you and your wife have
this conversation Jade's right and we go
okay what what's what's our reality one
of the options is for you to step up and
go all right baby's going to be little
I'm going to be there it's Mama's more
important than you are right now bro let
me just lay that out for you come on I
got three they want mama teenager
they still my wife knows everything
about what's going on in this kid life I
don't know anything it's not cuz my
head's insan they just tell her
everything Jade and so mama is more
important Tanner and in this season
specifically here's what I'd be thinking
how many hours can I work look can I
make some extra money to accomplish the
same thing Jade is saying I just think
you got to consider do I bust it work
some crazy hours knowing that I'm making
life better for little one and Mama
that's right and uh it's a season it's a
season I just have to push that well
regardless and and sorry we we're
belaboring this but regardless there is
something that needs to happen whether
you decide to work more she decides to
go back to work to pay off this debt
there's still this long-term picture of
okay you still got to put 3 to six
months we still you know are saving for
kids college and I'm challenging this
48,000 income longterm not just with a
side hustle cuz you're not going to want
a side hustle until you pay your house
off right we've got to look at what it's
going to look like to get this court
income up over the Long Haul and is it
just you or is it you guys working
together for a short term to accomplish
that yeah great advice and
congratulations young man exciting hey
uh go ahead and uh let me get a little
extra naps between now and when the baby
comes cuz you also aren't going to be
sleeping whether you're working extra or
not just part of the deal s it's going
to be okay you'll make it this is the
Ramy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast preapproval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$55,000 seller guarantee gives your
offer the best chance of being accepted
the home buyer Edge from Churchill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
[Applause]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman J warshaw joins me the phone
number for you to jump in is
88255 225 if you're new to the program
yes we talk a lot about money but a big
part of your money life is your work
life it is your greatest wealth building
tool that is your income and uh I help
folks win in their work life and so
we'll take those work rated calls
anything you want to talk about on that
that issue and I promise you Jade's got
an opinion on that too so you get uh you
get plenty of advice on that let's go to
Mark now in Portland Oregon Mark how can
we
help hello hello Mark you're live what's
happening alrighty so I have kind of
like a weird multifaceted question um I
am a um 100% disabled veteran but I'm
still like total impermanent and I'm
still allowed to work though okay um I I
have pretty much all my GI bill bill um
and I have minimal student loan debt
from uh getting my degree and I have my
I got my bachelor's in mechanical
engineering um but kind of the big kind
of Crux to what I'm wondering is like I
get a one-time uh student federal
student loan
forgiveness uh from the because of the
nature of my disability um from being in
the Navy
um so I'm kind of like trying to see
like is it worth it to just go to grad
school and then just uh max out the
student loans and just get them forgiven
it seems kind of sketchy to me a little
bit what hold on a second hold onal hold
on hold on hold on so what what would
the Masters what would the Masters be in
and why would you get it um it would
probably be a master's in mechanical
engineering uh focused more on like
building science like building science
and the built environment that's kind of
what I'm doing now so would that set you
up for growth financially through
promotions yeah yeah it would um so what
sketchy because he has the GI
bill because I can uh use my GI Bill
that pays for the entire tuition and I
get a housing typen like if I were to be
going staying in
Portland uh I would be getting 2,300
bucks a month taxfree while in school so
and then on top of the oop sorry good oh
go ahead I had one more question but go
ahead and then on top of that if I were
to take out student loans I could take
out up to 65,000 a year um for the two
years um to do that to kind of offset
the loss of income that I have
now uh and then another kind of weird
aspect to this too is like this would be
like if I were to do that that would be
more than what I'm making now with the
GI Bill and those loans because there's
no taxes associated with that but um and
my wife is also in medical school right
now too so just kind
of the money is kind of fungible because
we're married but like realistically a
lot of the money would probably end up
going towards like reducing her loans so
let me get let me let me make sure I got
my head around this because some I'll be
honest like with all the military
payments and stuff like that sometimes
it get gets confusing so you've got a
little bit of existing student loan debt
how much is that yeah 10K 10K will the
GI bill pay for that pay that off no but
I could get it forgiven right now if I
wanted to but okay so just one thing at
just one thing at a time because I want
to help you but I also want to make sure
that people listening understand why
won't the GI Bill cover that because
it's he's already done that but already
have that the GI bill would cover you
going to grad school correct yes so my
question is why can't you just use the G
Bill to go to grad school if that's what
you want to do and why can't you use the
other piece that you had the federal
student loan forgiveness because of your
disability to pay off the 10,000 what's
wrong with
that yeah that's kind of what I'm
thinking but to me and this is where I'm
like kind of the moral and ethical
dilemma like I could do all that but
then I could also take out more student
loans and then those would get forgiven
because it's just a onetime deal so what
you want to do you want to take out
extra student loans knowing that you can
get the federal government forgiveness
yes yes and not use those for
education I mean it would be covering my
housing expenses and all that like
that's kind of where I thought I heard
you say I thought hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on I also
thought I heard you say that would go
towards paying off some of your wife's
medical loan debt as well so you're
talking about taking out a student loan
to use personally
well you can use student loans to cover
your housing expenses but you say the GI
Bill already gave you a stipend for the
housing that's just for like living
expenses and other Portland's like a
more expensive city but hold up okay
hold on hold on hold on because I I I
I'm hearing you but I'm also feeling a
little it I'm the fact that we're going
back there is a shady quality to it
because the GI Bill covers what we would
call living expenses right like whether
that's rent or other things that goes
along with living but you're saying I
would take out student loans to continue
to do that my problem with that is the
GI Bill saying hey we have a sipon for
that that's what that money is intended
for the federal student loan forgiveness
student loans by definition should be to
pay for education so it does bother me
related expenses well no not necessarily
I mean related expenses yes but are you
go are you living on campus to go to
school no no I have a house and a
mortgage and a job so that's what I'm
saying like currently so I would stop
working to go to school yeah I feel like
that's a little weird it's not like
you're going to school you're taking out
student loans this is covering room and
board and dormatory and that I mean by
they are student loans which by the way
I wouldn't tell somebody to take out
student loans anyway but in this case
they're forgiven I just
I'm gonna so wait a second let me and
and Par pardon us we're we're not trying
to be dense not it's just the way you
this up it's strange well it's strange
because you know it's not right that's
what I think yeah it's not a stupid so
hold on so you agree that you just said
okay we finally got it I didn't mean to
lead you there this is my first lawyer
moment you don't feel this is right
uh-uh and I don't feel like it's right
it is sketchy yeah well then why are you
calling us asking us if we think you
should do something sketchy because free
money makes you do funny things Ken well
it ain't free it's on the taxpayers back
illegal like with friend my friend
listen to me first of all two things
since you
called now I'm going to tell you what I
think it's sketchy because it's wrong
it's wrong yeah because you're taking
out money that is that's all taxpayer
funded my friend I'm paying for that
Jade's paying for that I could go around
the room we it's nice people out in the
lobby I don't think they would like to
pay for that either they don't feel good
about
it but my Crux of it the CR of it for me
the reasoning behind it because I feel
like we do have to point out the
reasoning for me the reasoning is
student loans really should be for
education and I don't think in your case
I don't think the living expenses are an
expense of you getting your education if
you were going to live on campus if you
were staying in a dormatory if you had
you know get apartment in another city
to take the classes then I could see
okay like maybe but in your case because
this is this is your situation I don't
see how your personal mortgage has
anything to do with you choosing to go
to grad school and so for that reason I
think that's where the ethical barrier
is for me um we're agreeing with you you
said it was sketchy we think it's
sketchy and and let me just say this
you're a great American you served our
country uh disability because of it
you're a great American you're a great
American and you know it's sketchy so
this up to you my friend I don't think
you kind of I don't think you can
rationalize this uh for me or for J my
head and I haven't been able to well
then trust your gut look if you were
like if you had said something I'm just
trying to come up with some scenarios if
you were like hey when I was in the
military you I don't know I'm just
trying to come up with a way that maybe
this m like if you inquired a bunch of
other debt because of school but I just
don't see that like this just doesn't
yeah it does hit right you're a good man
a great American thank you for your
service your gut's right we agree with
your gut uh and and you've got a bright
future in front of you you don't need
this wife's going to get through Medical
School you guys going to be fine don't
try to shortcut it you guys are on the
right path thanks for the call this is
the Ramsey Show
MH
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Jade warshaw we're
here for you taking your money calls
your work calls today 88255 2258
225 okay so um you said I'm going to do
this yeah we I guess we do it in the
comment section this is when we need a
we need a poll feature is this real it's
real it's happening okay okay this
happen I didn't clear it by James and
you know he'll talk to me about it I
like this this is this is hard hitting
like it hardit he likes it all right so
here it is I'm going to set it up
quickly I don't want to eat up a lot of
time on that's my little uh friendly ass
well you're eating it up now Ken come on
all right here it is fair fair point I
see what you did there last call okay
last call gentleman served our country
was in the Navy disabled and has the GI
bill has 10,000 in loans uh the GI Bill
won't cover but then he also has the
ability to get as much as
$65,000 uh in student loans and he was
thinking hey should I just take that out
live off of that while I'm getting this
Masters blah blah blah blah blah he said
be wife's going to be a doctor all that
yeah he said he felt sketchy about it
and we told him it was sketchy because
at the end of the day he wasn't using
the money for Education he was using it
for other stuff but during the
commercial break you said it does feel
sketchy but as my my portion of being a
taxpayer because of his service for our
country I would be fine with him doing
it and I said no no no I said I'd be
willing because the the the forgiveness
is taxpayer dollar
65,000 and I said as a taxpayer I would
be willing this guy this guy served our
country to the point of 100% disability
I would be willing to give him my
portion which is
0.0091 of that 65,000 and my question
was if if enough other folks in the chat
say I'd give him my portion too then
that means it's like hey all right so
what say you in the comments have at it
would you give your
and I would be I'm happy to go on record
as saying I am a bleeding heart
conservative let me Define that can
don't make me give you the side ey can
that means that I feel really really bad
for his situation in play and I'm so
grateful for his service but but can I
am not going to donate my tax dollars
it's less than his I'm s this is such a
silly argument it's about principal not
actual percentage H write that
down you're sounding stingy uh
sounding principled and it gets called
stingy principal Works whether it's
stingy or generous so there you go
comment away that's all we got let the
let the people speak people in the in
the a trying to sway the audience
there's a couple of folks in the
audience look at this guy look at this
guy they're 100% with me wait it's less
than a penny stop it's a principal thank
you Deanna Deanna is with me oh man
y'all are funny look there's no right or
wrong answer she's a whole another
situation that doesn't even count what
does that mean I don't know we need to
move on is what that means on y'all put
the drop it in the drop it in the
comments cuz I really want to know would
you give your hey Penny for this man
65,000 that's not the point you reframed
it it's should taxpayer dollars go to
him living off of student loans no
should not I don't care how much the
amount is let the people speak saying if
someone wanted to be generous it all
right we'll see that's all I'm saying it
doesn't mean generous versus
stingy all right Christina is up in Salt
Lake
Christina how can we
help yeah well I'm totally with you on
that you who you you you you support Ken
yeah thank you very much appreciate your
vote November
folks yeah um so I have um I have a
mortgage it's at like uh it was
originally 295 it's about 2 a right now
uhhuh and I have PMI okay because we
really we really needed to move back to
where we were and uh it was uh anyway um
we also have $330,000 in student loan
debt and when my husband and I went to
college it was 3% so we we were in the
good good time right yeah so the
question is should I pay off my mortgage
to get rid of the PMI or should I pay
off a student
and my PMI is about $43 a month um the
the short answer is no I would not pay
off your mortgage first to get off get
rid of PMI I would walk the baby steps
which is paying off your all your debt
except your mortgage so it's almost the
complete opposite um and there's good
reason for that your student I mean your
student loans are debt and it's costing
you money every single month and there's
something to be said for when you get on
a plan walking the plan the best way the
way that the baby steps is constructed
is the most efficient way to paying off
debt saving money and Building Wealth
and it's not just me saying that this
plan has been around for over 30 years
and millions of people have walked it
this way so the thing about it um
Christina is everybody out there goes my
situation is a little bit different and
because my situation is like this I
think it would work better if I did it
like this right now the fact of the
matter is you can get off this phone
you're grown you can do whatever you
want and I'm not going to be mad at you
we're both going to sleep good at night
but if you're asking my opinion I do
think that the best use of your money is
to get these student loans off your
plate free and clear I think this 20%
PMI thing it's just like a bad song that
won't get out of your head like it's
really not it's cool to save money on
things but it's really not in your world
it's really not that big of an important
thing because once you get this debt
paid off once you get three to six
months saved once you start investing
15% you're going to be on such a great
trajectory and by then probably the
amount of money that you've paid off on
your mortgage I don't know what your
payment is I don't know what your
interest rate is but you might be close
to Knocking that PMI out anyway cuz once
you hit it you know it's off like once
you get to that 20% it's out and if
you're not there by then then you will
be sooner than later does that make
sense yeah well we hit the uh the
interest rate at like 4.8 and so it's
not great but we just thought 00 a
year was kind of high it is PM PMI it is
but you're G to be there again
everybody's got that kind of why I'm the
exception to the rule and my point is if
you walk through the plan ultimately
you're going to have more money to throw
towards this and you're going to have
the piece of not having debt having your
savings do you have do you have any
savings 3 to six months
months we have about um like 7,000 in
savings exactly so my point my point in
this is I think you're trying to do the
right things but I think you're trying
to do the right things in the wrong
order and at the end of the day you
still have debt you don't have quite
enough savings and you got PMI right so
let's start doing this stuff in order so
that we're not kind of you know it's
almost like I put a little money here I
put a little money there I put a little
money there and you look up and it's
like yeah but I still have debt and I
still don't have savings like you're not
accomplishing what at the end of the day
we all want which is that peace with our
money and you get that piece when that
debts paid off when you've got that the
right amount of savings because for you
guys 7,000 is not enough and then at the
end of that road the final thing is
we're paying off the mortgage with
intentionality and if you want to go
intensely for a while to get rid of that
PMI that's your business but does that
does that make sense for
you yeah no that's fine I just uh I just
wanted to know what you guys thought cuz
we
aren't full disclosure we're not fully
following the the baby steps but like we
have all of our cars are paid off our
campers paid off paid off that's awesome
but I do think that uh I have an analogy
in my brain I don't know that it's
appropriate but oh I kind of intrigue
now well it's like if I if if I'm
married and I got this from my pastor if
I'm married I'm 100% committed and it it
it it gets real funky when I say hey I'm
committed on Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday but Sunday
Sunday is when I get into it like that
doesn't work he'd be like um this is not
a full commitment and so we would not be
able to have the marriage that we should
have because I'm not fully committed and
I think it's the same way with this plan
when it comes to your money when you
commit to this plan and you go all in on
it you get the full benefit of the plan
and it's all that it could be and all
that it should be but when you take
Sundays and you're like on Sundays
that's when I you know I don't know use
my credit cards and on Sundays that's so
it's like you get some of it you're
paying off the cars you're doing that
that's great I would love for you to go
fully committed to this plan and see
what happens next great stuff you said
uh in that call it's like a bad song you
can't get out of your head my nomination
you can't touch this and see Hammer
great hour Jade James our fearless
leader and you the people this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
a
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win with your money
and with your work and with your
relationships all of those somehow are
very interconnected we want to help you
win in all three areas because that
means you're winning in your life 8825
5225 8825 5225 that's the phone number
to jump in I'm Ken Coleman Jade warshaw
joins me
this hour and we are here for you so
let's get to it we're going to this is
always exciting I always love when they
tell us on the screen where people are
from yes because it gives you an idea
like the world's a really big place yeah
and uh we've got Jan on the line but I
think this is
Mula Montana is that right J Missoula
Montana yes also a little bit of a it's
a hard ass not a soft as Missoula
correct I got it Missoula Montana it's
like a z yeah yes how can we
help um so I am a relatively new Widow
and I Had A Series of Unfortunate Events
this past year and I resorted to racking
up credit card debt which I knew was a
big no no yeah but um I'm living on half
of the income that my husband used to
bring in and now I'm backpedaling
because I can't pay the debt off and so
I am either contemplating credit card
like debt consolidation or just closing
the account out and just seeing if the
car the credit card companies will work
with me I'm very limited on the income
that I can make um and so I just don't
know what the best option to do is what
happened um so my husband um was ill and
had a very rare tumor that the NIH was
studying and he um developed Co and
essentially died from coid but he had
coties so sorry for you so yeah I was a
state home mom uh he was the bre winner
for you know 21 years of our life we had
four kids so wow I'm sorry any life
insurance yeah no life insurance no
savings no 401K I'm sorry um my gosh I I
I do want to say that we hear we hear
this a lot like something traumatic
happens and there is more spending that
happens in a lot of cases after that
whether it's just out of emotional
spending or whether it's truly like I
haven't figured out how to make life
tick without this major bread winner and
in your case because there was no
insurance and because you've got four
kids that does put a wrench on it how
old are the
kids um so my oldest is 20 and so he's
not really in my he's in my household
but not directly in my financial
household okay my I have a 17-year-old
son a 12-year old daughter and a
10-year-old daughter and I I don't have
a traditional income I rely on death
benefit and the reason my my two girls
have health issues and so one of them H
takes a medication that's like $9,000 a
month wow so I have to rely on Medicaid
so my income is very limited as to what
I can bring in what is to have her
medicine covered yeah so let's let's
dive into that so what is the limit in
order to get the medication covered via
Medicaid what's the limit on you
financially to what you could actually
earn 26,000 a year isn't that crazy yeah
it's keeping you in poverty um let me
ask you this the two girls in their
health issues is that also keeping you
at home it would not allow you a
traditional let's say that we could get
child care and we got a great job with
great benefits that help with the let's
just assume all of that is that even
possible for you to be able to work
outside a home it is possible I do clean
homes so I I have a couple of homes that
I clean a couple times a week um to to
get some cash um you're
keeping on purpose yeah but but it
low I am cap I am like cap at to what I
can bring in and so my kids go to the
doctors quite often and so so I'm
multiple times a week I my schedule kind
of has to be flexible but if I could
find a job that I could get this all
taken care of that that would be amazing
well can we play out some real numbers
to see what it would take have you have
you have you done that I mean I don't
want to do work you've already done but
what if we sat
yeah go ahead I was going to say what if
we sat so one child's medication is 900
did you say a month 9,000 9,000 9,000
girl okay I I feel it I feel
it that's 9,000 a month and then what do
you have a
mortgage I do not I rent can I ask
what's your
rent my rent it's currently 950 but it's
going to be going up at the first of the
year to 1250 can I ask a question again
about this medicine um if you had
regular Insurance what portion of the
9,000 would the regular insurance
cover so whenever we did some research
because my husband was offered a a great
job offer years ago and in Marketplace
and stuff like that we could not find an
insurance company that would cover the
medicine because it's it's human growth
hormone and she takes a lot of it um and
so it's kind of one of those tricky
medications that's I I don't know the
ins and outs of it I just know whenever
we contacted health insurance companies
about three years ago we could not find
one to where the rise that he would be
getting would even be beneficial for
us I see what was he making before he
passed 48,000 a year so how did Medicaid
allow that that's what I'm wondering so
we had so my my son was in our home and
he was a minor and then my husband was
in our home and so they go by how many
people are in your home
and now that my son is no longer a minor
and my husband is deceased my my family
went from six people in my home to
technically four people in my home so
they they they deduct about
$10,000 um per person who is no longer
considered under your
household I see okay I get it the math
the math maths this is so maddening to
me that that you get penalized you get
you get some help and then you get
penalized um because 9,000
is extraordinary uh even if you were
making 150,000 a year that's of course
that's that's almost all your take home
you know it just eats up so
much um and you've got debt how much
credit card debt have you racked up just
under 20,000 I so I had a master maneed
at the beginning of the year and that
went septic and that led was a domino
effect and I was not able to do my
normal house cleaning for about five
months and so um I just started I was
like well I'll just use the credit cards
and I'll just work extra and then that
it just was too big of a problem for me
to to get my feet back under and so I
have not been using the credit cards um
for months now but um does Medicaid
cover does Medicaid cover the entire
amount of the medicine yes Medicaid so
my two daughters have both had open
heart surgeries multiple ones they cover
100% of all of their medical needs
medications surgeries even if we have to
travel to Seattle for their surgeries
and they also kind of provide Travel
Assistance um so I I'm out of pocket for
my children's medical needs is zero I I
I pay
nothing I would just I would want to
look into other even if they're outside
insurances anything else that might have
the ability to cover this because you
living on
$26,000 with four a year with four kids
I don't see how that's sustainable
longterm and I would just want to get as
much information as I can at the very
least can we connect her with Xander and
see what the heck could be out there
that could help offset this
$9,000 a month that you're paying hey I
wish we could have been way more help to
you I feel like we spent more time
learning than helping so here's what
we're going to do we're going to get you
connected for free to our one of our
best financial coaches here in the
building and they're going to walk you
through what you can do hang on the line
we'll take care
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me hey if
you're new to the program or you've been
listening for quite some time we would
love for you to help us spread the word
if you're enjoying the program uh like
the videos you're watching on YouTube uh
give us a follow on podcast and then uh
a five star review and share share share
uh whatever platform that you listen or
watch on uh we would be so grateful we
want to help as many people as possible
uh get out of the system The Matrix if
you will where they just think that
broke and and working a sucky job and
having a okay or crappy relationship is
just well that's just life we want to
help as many people as possible so do
help us do that let's go to Houston
Texas where Kristen awaits Kristen how
can we
help hey um glad to be on I have a
question sets four and five primarily
okay um really on how to actually make
them both happen at the same
time okay is it just baby steps four and
five or baby steps four five and six
four five and six but I mean we can't
afford to pay off our home early yet so
we're you know we're working towards um
getting up to that 15% reach right now
we're doing about 11 and a half% of our
income toward retire we're also putting
some for the kids and we're kind of
worried that our we're not going to have
as much as we want saved up for the kids
because we and our kids really young
right so we have a lot more time before
retirement versus is when the kids are
going to go to college I mean our
daughter just turned seven and she's
going to graduate high school at 17 have
10 years left of that but we still have
35 plus years so retirement let's work
through these percentages a little bit
so I can understand where your money is
going so you're completely debt free
except the mortgage let's say there's
25% that's going to your mortgage is it
that or less or
more um I think it's just
under with the mortgage property taxes
and insurance I think it's a about 28
okay so that's a little higher that's
okay then let's say you're giving
10% yes okay so there's 35% and let's
say 15% is supposed to go to retirement
so we're at 50% of our income in your
case
53% what's happening to the other 50% of
your
income cuz that's assuming you're
investing house going well you know
groceries and the kids how many kids
activities and we have two kids okay two
kids so four four four people in the
house what's the income combined income
for you and your
husband um so I just started a part-time
job so may we don't know how much
that'll end up being over the year but
my husband makes 115 a year okay what
I'm going to propose just a few months
ago what I'm going to propose is that
something in your budget the other 50%
something there is inflated because
essentially what you would have if
you're not you know I think you said
you're at 11% so the other you know 54%
of your budget is inflated somewhere so
are you on an every dollar
budget yes we've been using every dollar
and I do know one area is inflated and
it just our property taxes because we
just bought this house and they didn't
protest the value and so that should be
going down a few hundred a month oh okay
so that's good so that's going to help
you get from 28 to
25 yes and so in January how much of
this should I dedicate to actually
getting 15% to retirement or I you know
do like 13 and a half and then have a
little bit more for the college the kids
college fund I would do the 15% no
matter what because their time is going
to come no matter what when you have to
retire right what I would start talking
about with the kids how old are
they we have a almost six-year-old and a
seven-year-old okay so you've got a
little bit of time there and it's not to
say that you can't put any money aside
because again with baby step five we're
not saying it has to be this specific
amount I mean if you can get50 and $100
in there every once in a while that's
something but I want you to get to this
15% as quickly as possible and then as
things start to change with your uh
property tax or whatever the thing you
said that was inflated right now you're
going to start to see a difference that
$300 to $400 is a big deal but I really
want you going through your budget with
a fine tooth comb because there might be
some other areas that for you seem
normal but when you really start to peel
back and go okay like what's what's a
bigger priority for me to do this or for
me to make sure I'm getting at least 100
bucks a month into a 529 right and then
the thing with the mortgage you might
you know right now again it's it's about
being intentional it there doesn't have
to be a layer of intensity to that
whatsoever at this point so if you had
you know ideas that you were going to be
paying double payments in this season
maybe or not because of the age of your
kids but there will be a season where
where you will be able to do that but I
really want you to look at this in term
of percentage because this plan works
for a reason and it works because of
those percentages so for some you got to
really look and say okay what's the 50%
going to is somebody in private school
is there um is there something about
your budget that kind of feels like oh
maybe that's what it is other than that
property insurance for three or four 300
more well so had a three Monon emergency
fund for a long time but we have been
working towards the full six months as
well right now we're about a four and a
half month but we are still contributing
a few hundred every month emergency fund
and we and we have been putting $100 for
between the two kids every month for
wait a sec wait a minute wait a
minute this is it this is the money this
is where your money is I guess you're
doing the most you're doing all of it
like pull back on the emergency fund
then and be okay with like the four and
a half months no I mean if you guys want
what you think if you used some of it
and you need to replenish it back to six
months go on and replenish it I want you
to get back to 15% whatever it takes you
to get to 15% investing and if you want
to replenish your savings back to 6
months and if if you're putting $100 a
month in your $529 that's great the
biggest thing with that $529 is
projecting out to the Future and really
understanding what is what's actually
going to be there when your kids get to
college so you can start having those
conversations now but I I think you're
doing better than you think you are I
think you're just I think the the couple
hundred that you're putting aside to try
to replenish this emergency fund plus
the overage that's going on with the
property tax right now I mean that could
be 6 $100 that's a lot of money right
yeah so it just seems like you're kind
of in this limbo phase once that fire
goes out then you're going to be like oh
there's the money that that's where it
went yeah I I I'm hearing a mindset
Kristen where you're just feeling almost
guilty that you're not doing as much as
you'd like in you step the steps aren't
a uh
Taskmaster they are a guide and you move
within the steps when you need to so it
feels like you're beating yourself up a
little bit and you shouldn't be you're
doing enough you're fine if you want to
replenish or boost the baby I mean baby
step three then do that and to J's point
we just want you getting on a consistent
investing but don't be you know beating
yourself up over this you're not doing
anything wrong you're you're doing right
you're just doing a lot does that
help definitely it it's always nice to
have another perspective because yeah
when you're in it you kind of see all
the flaws and not the strengths
necessarily that's it that's it I just
want mindset right now to go we're doing
a great job you're ahead we're ahead of
just about everybody in America have you
seen the data so give yourself a break
focus on the
priorities not the productivity part of
this I think we get hung up on well Dave
says uh Jade says bab St four five and
six at the same time wait a second life
happens uh the steps are there for a
reason there's a reason why threes
before four yeah in the point of four
five and six obviously brilliant what I
just said I just heard how silly that
sounded I what did you say there's a
reason why three is before four but the
point is the emergency fund is more
important I know but the emergency fund
is more important than the 15% that's
right there's a reason why we have it
there so if you feel comfortable with 6
months then that's what you do then back
up I guess that's the point I'm try
there's me to Madness yeah don't get
hung up on uh how well I'm doing in each
thing at the same time it's what matters
most to me within the steps yes so
Kristen deep breath mhm off this phone
call going I'm doing great I'm going to
continue to do great and I'm going to be
fine
yes yeah and I'll have to have my
husband hear that too because that's
right more critically than I do okay so
this is great Kristen you know this is
on YouTube right now right yes so you
could just you could just have him get
to this moment and go look at what Jade
said look at what Ken said look at the
guy in the goofy shirt you got to listen
to that guy doing great and so what's
his
name his name is Michael M Micha you're
doing fine relax yes Michael and Kristen
take Kristen out for a steak dinner man
come I know that's right y'all been
working hard come on you guys are
crushing all right don't move quick
break we're back with more of your calls
this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
helping you win with your money your
work and your relationships this is the
ramsy show I'm Ken Coleman Jade warshaw
joins me the phone number to jump in is
8825 5225 8825
5225 Diana is on the line in Providence
Road Island Diana how can we help hi I
just had a question about a car
Le okay
mhm I am my lease is up in May I owe
approximately 18,000 on it I was
wondering if I should go trade in and
buy a
car in May or sell the car or sell the
car back and go by and take a hit for
2,000 and buy a car for approximately
8,000 okay walk through that again so
one option is to buy it at
18 correct and the other option is to
come out of pocket for two grand and
just get out of the lease yes and then
you go do you have some money set aside
because you said buy a car for eight
grand so that means you've got the eight
grand set aside if you do that I I don't
I was going to do a home equity line of
credit well now no okay um let's let's
let's look at this um do the entire
advice sing please like it's a musical
you don't want me to do that Ken um well
maybe you do but I'm not going to so the
first question is do you have what other
debt do you have I have about $38,000 in
credit cards 38,000 and I own a home and
I owe about
23,000 230,000 230,000 on the home um do
you have any money set aside do you have
any cash that you could get your hands
on stocks uh some money nothing's your
inome pull out of my retirement well no
don't pull out of your
retirement 105,000 a year $105,000 a
year so you've got some money coming in
it's just you are you married you have
kids it's um I have a kid 10 years old
okay so here's the thing um I'm not
opposed to you getting out of this car
and taking a hit if I felt like you
could take it without going into debt to
cover another car because you need a car
it's you and your 10-year-old um you got
this 18,000 that if you bought turned
around and bought the car and then you
got the 38,000 of
debt
umre all right so let me let me just
jump in really quick while you're
thinking here what how would you come up
with the two grand out of pocket or in
other words how long would it take you
to scrape the two grand together so that
when you did turn in the lease you had
it probably two and a half two months
okay how's your CR how's your um how's
your credit
that's the problem I just did a debt
consolidation program and they hadn't
paid any of my credit cards for
approximately six months so my credit
just dropped trally yeah and and you
know in some cases it's like if you have
$188,000 car loan you know you're trying
to get out of it or a car loan in
general we might tell you to get a small
loan for the difference so you can get
out of it and get just a cash car $5,000
something like that so at least your
debts going from1 18 to 5 right um in
this case that might not be the case
because of your credit um do you drive a
lot in that car yes here's the thing I
the 18,000 car with your income the fact
that you have an $118,000 car that you
would purchase um or that you'd be you
know trying to get the lease off of
doesn't bother me as far as the price of
it but because you've got this other
almost 40,000 in debt I kind of hate
that for you how quickly could you pay
off uh let me look at this your credit
cards in the debt snowball how many how
many are there is it just one or two or
is it lots of little
ones it's about there's eight there's
eight and do they all are they all less
expensive than the 18,000 car pay the
the car the
18,000 combined no individual are they
all less expensive oh yeah okay are they
in the debt consolidation program though
that's what I'm not understanding
did yes but I was going to try to get a
personal loan and pay
off okay um I think I think we're trying
to look for an out but at the end of the
day you've just got you just got you
just got debt and you're just going to
have to pay it off because you don't
have the money to get a less expensive
car like you don't have the way to get a
loan to do that and you don't have the
credit to do it um that's my question
Jade so I got a question okay for you
and Diana um if it's going to take you
two months give or take to come up with
a 2,000 to get out of the lease how long
would it take you I mean is it fair to
say that you could uh let's say 6 to 8
months from now have about six to eight
grand if you if you started working
extra hours you started doing everything
you can here's where I'm going that's
right cuz how much time do you have
before you have to make this
decision uh it's dueing May oh you've
got time okay that okay so here's where
I'm going there you go Ken I'm working
like a maniac yes and I'm going to save
up money I'm going to get out of the
lease yes and I'm going to Fork over the
2 Grand plus I'm going to have about six
grand and I'm going to get myself a
decent car that's right and it's not
great Diana it's not great but it'll get
you from A to Z while you get out of
this situation yeah crucial piece of
information is you've got time I'm
thinking we're deciding today you've got
time so take get 6,000 what as much as
you can save up yeah because Watch What
Happens what's the lease right now what
are you paying every month on that lease
375 so we get a 375 $5 raise in about 6
months hey let's go now the 375 goes
into paying off so you can get out of
this with 105,000 and listen you can
find a way Mama Bear yeah you don't have
a baby you got a 10-year-old so we
figure out some super cheap child care
whatever you're working like crazy let's
see if we can make an additional 50
Grand I'm going to put that challenge
out there could you make an additional
50 Grand in 2024 and I think the answer
is yes and and if that whole 50 Grand
minus taxes of course goes toward
getting out of debt I think you're free
quick M well at the very least if she
has 105 income they can live on oh there
50 of it that's exactly right like where
are you cutting expenses what are you
selling how much are you working I think
you can get out of this but I would
definitely get out of the lease yeah
okay yeah that's good all right I
appreci you helped greatly I owe you
guys you're awesome by the way I love
that Rhode Island accent can I just say
that yeah gotta pck the C when she
started talking about the C I was like
yeah I wish I talk like that I got this
goofy southern thing going on I I like
that Rhode Island accent that's
fantastic hey uh how about our how about
our backyard uh we take calls from from
local Ashley's calling from Nashville
talk have no idea what he's talking
about folks I try to keep her on her
toes let's go to Ashley who's calling
from
Nashville hi hi everybody very excited
hi so um quick question my um fiance
um his company just decided to give a
12% contribution directly to the 401
case so does he need to contribute the
additional 50% or just the three or
additional 3% with that is it a
continuous match or it's just they just
did this onetime
thing no um they're going to continue do
as he's working there so 12% every
single years it's is not a match um you
know when it comes to baby step four and
for those listening baby step four is
putting 15% of your take you know 15%
monthly into retirement um the reason
for that and I kind of want to get to
the reasoning first and then it'll
inform why my answer is what it is the
reason for that is we want you building
the muscle of investing your own money
into retirement because he's at this job
now but let's just say on down the line
he decides to go work someplace else and
they don't do that match or they don't
do that contribution over the course of
the year you want to know that no matter
what you've built it into your lifestyle
and you've built it into your budget
that we just invest and we invest 15%
and this is off the gross number and
that's just our habit in life so yes I
long all of that to say yes I still want
you investing your 15% and think of any
match or additional contribution or
anything like that that's just icing on
a on a very delicious cake you know what
I'm saying oh making me hungry now
that's great that they're matching that
much or that they're cont contributing
that much um it sounds like even
regardless of what you put in so that's
really good yeah I love it thank you so
much Ashley for the call all right uh so
we got to do these things called
commercial breaks uh but hang on because
we have another segment coming your way
with some great calls she's Jade warshaw
I'm Ken Coleman and this is the ramsy
show after these messages we'll be right
[Music]
back
oh
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is with me the
phone number is 8825
55225 our scripture of the day comes
from Proverbs
21:31 the horse is made ready for the
day of battle but Victory Belongs to the
Lord and then our quote from The Iron
Lady herself Margaret Thatcher you may
have to fight a battle more than once to
win it love it isn't that true yeah all
right let's go to Irvine California
Bonnie is awaiting Bonnie how can we
help hey Ken hey Jade um it's such an
honor to be speaking with both of you
today thanks so much for taking your
time to speak with me well you bet I'm a
little nervous so sorry you're doing
great that was quite an intro you're
crushing it what's up thank you I have a
question regarding completing a
bachelor's degree okay um I have an
associates degree which I earned in 2020
and I've been working full-time in
Insurance since then I've recently
applied to um a fouryear university and
I got accepted and I'm just having gold
feet and I think it's not uh the right
decision for me to go based on uh my
finances okay let's let's see if there's
any evidence to back up your gut how
about that all right absolutely all
right so you don't think it's a wise
decision because you're finances paint
the financial picture for
us well you know overall my husband and
I are doing really well um we make
roughly about 125 before taxes okay um
and we the only debt that we have is
3,000 in credit cards which is just mine
um and then we also have um about 33,000
left on a loan um from his parents but
and he provided they provided a down
payment on our home for so um payment
bucks for that and then um roughly about
323 off on a mortgage okay so 36,000 of
Consumer Debt and how much is the
schooling going to cost if you were to
do this so it would be about 16,000 um
that be going fulltime for the next two
and a half years total yeah and that
means you're not working in the
insurance
job um it would actually I I could try I
would be yeah I would be working full
time only only 35 hours a week trying to
tackle both yeah okay um and the yeah
the reason that I'm I'm getting cold
feed is because there you know there are
personal reasons that I want to complete
this but ultimately I just feel guilty
spending $116,000 to complete school
when I don't know if it's necessarily
going to get me a heaven life well that
was my next question uh I love the I
love the personal reasons not going to
question those at all and because of
that I'm going to say I think you should
do it but I think you should do it later
not now absolutely I don't think you
should feel guilty about considering it
and I don't think this is ought to be
about guilt this just ought to be about
you know what it matters to me to get
the degree one day uh but I'm going to
do it when I can and when I can is
certainly after we pay off 36,000 in
Consumer Debt and then get to the point
where I can cash flow or I have saved it
up to then be able to do it and I I
think you the degree is always going to
be there and I I think you should put it
off that's what you're thinking and
feeling and I couldn't agree more with
your feelings
here yeah it's it's definitely coming
from um wanting to plan ahead and and
set things right for the future like I
my husband and I really want to start a
family in the next couple years but I'm
just you know kind of reverse
engineering it and going well if I'm
going to put all this time and effort
into complaining school you know I could
be spending ending just the same amount
of time getting a part-time job maybe
making $20 an hour and I you know I was
doing the numbers and I'm like I could
yeah you know I could earn 16,000 in one
year versus it over two and a half years
I would just i' press
pause not the delete button the pause
button it's gonna be there you good with
that absolutely yeah yeah you're awesome
I think it's simple press a pause button
yeah you bet thank you for the call love
it love it love it uh let's go to Mel in
Salt Lake City Mel how can
we hi Hi how are you
Mel I'm good um my question is pretty
straightforward should we sell our
current home to pay off the debt that we
have and move into my parents home who
are going on a church mission for a
couple years or should we keep it and
rent it out we're feeling a little bit
tight because we're about4 00 every
month and that's like earlier this year
we cut out all of the
extras and why are you negative4 1400
every
month
um that's just like basic needs I mean
this like basic necessities is so you
aren't making enough money yeah what's
what's the income between you and your
husband like a 100 thou about 100,000 he
makes about
85 12 and how much debt do you guys
have total 180,000 okay 100,000 bringing
in yeah so what would hold on she was
about ready to give us something 130
what well I was gonna say the monthly
payment for just loans we have about
60,000 in student loans 53,000 in car
loans and 60,000 in credit cards okay
I'm looking at monthly payment for all
of that is
2687 okay the cars yeah 53,000 in car
loans yes we got to get out of these
cars so do we I mean we owed 26 and 27
on 2016 cars that are
125,000 miles one of them um one of the
reasons that was one thing we had car
problems all year so we we just put into
that car almost $10,000 this year we had
the transmission had to be completely
rebuilt so none of they're not worth
anything is that what you're telling me
no no they're they're worth I mean we
could so if you sold the 26,000 one what
would it what's it worth on Kelly Blue
Book um it's in the low 20s okay like 21
23 so are you like maybe 3,000 upside
down probably okay and then what about
the 27,000
one um that's a that one's in good shape
we could we could break even on it okay
break even on that how quickly could you
scrape could you guys live on one car
for a
while we have five kids you've got five
kids okay that's brings that's something
in here here's a super quick question
I'm I'm I'm gonna get in and get out on
this one if you all sell your house
clear off all this debt and go live
rentree with Mom and Dad or not at their
house while they're on this Mission this
isn't it may bail you out but it's not
going to change your life if you guys
don't fix what got you into this mess
you guys are living way way out of
bounds yeah I I think that you guys can
make this happen and I think that
whether or not you live in Mom's house
for a while or not is kind of besides
the point I want you to look at this
situation and see where the problem is
the problem is you keep taking on debt
you've got student loans you've got cars
you can't afford so I think you're going
to need to feel the pain a little bit on
this thing and I would get rid of one of
the cars I'd take the hit on the 3,000
scrape up $3,000 as quickly as you can
and get out of that one and scrape up a
little bit more money and one of you is
going to be driving a beater for a while
and then I'm going to look at this
100,000 income that you're making and
I'm going to look for any way that you
guys can add to that income over this
period of time because I don't really
like the idea of you guys renting out
your personal home I don't know how long
your family is going to be on the
mission field but if they should come
back sooner Suddenly It's like oh okay
like we got to KCK these folks out likee
I either sell it or stay but don't rent
it exactly um that's creating more
problems for you guys and you know your
house what's it
worth 800 800,000 like a 200 200
$200,000 Equity yeah $200,000 equity and
when did you buy
it um about two years ago yeah what does
your husband want to
do he doesn't want to sell the house I
would not sell it I wouldn't I would
work through this debt I think you guys
can do it and and I think it's going to
teach you a really great lesson at the
end and I think there's going to be some
pain involved here but I think that you
guys have the ability to get your income
up a 100,000 uh on with 180,000 of debt
I think that there's some real moves
that you guys can make to even this out
the average person is getting out of
debt in two years and under I think you
guys can be done with this in two uh
three years maximum if you guys work
hard if you don't you know this is up to
you guys how quickly you work this thing
what can each of you guys do to bring in
some extra money
um I mean I I feel like I'm maxed out
honestly like with time and I'm goinging
the kids and he he does he also does a
bunch of side H hustles he does music
work he does voiceover interpreting so
that's aside from his 85 job getting
these cars cleared out and you each
getting a couple of beaters is going to
be the ticket to you guys cleaning this
up super duper fast okay so that's thing
one on the list and then we're just
going through those baby steps man hey
thank you for the call Jade warshaw
great show thanks to everybody in the
booth keeping us on the air thank you
America this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
oh